hello i'm opportunistically andrew
heaton and this
is mostly weekly right so last week what
happened was
hillary clinton released her memoir
about the 2016 election entitled
what happened to deliver the definitive
clinton explanation of what happened
rather than the truly burning question
of what the
roller coaster it happened so i had my
head writer comb through the book these
were her reactions
thanks sarah here's the main takeaway
from what happened hillary got a sucky
deal
but she's also kind of a sucky
politician so
it's sort of like seeing someone get
chat upon by a bird
but then finding out that that person is
charlie sheen so
hillary appears to be suffering from
early onset idd
introspection deficit disorder the book
spends a lot of time
taking complete ownership of how her
actions are all your fault
come on rod ham even dominoes owned up
to their terrible pizza don't be the
papa john's of politicians
so here are the top three reasons
hillary clinton is not president hillary
clinton
according to not president hillary
clinton number one bernie sanders
clinton claims that she lost in part
because a disheveled socialist grandpa
promised wide-eyed millennials a college
tuition farting unicorn because hillary
clinton
never ever promised her constituents
something unrealistic no way
no number two the media ah the media
the classic bastion of right-wing
conspiracies
hillary blames the media for its free
coverage of donald trump
who yes did get millions of dollars
worth of free airtime by acting like a
jackass
when they could have been airing footage
of her zingers like
this i'm trying to figure out how we get
them to have pokemon go to the polls
so relevant number three white women
apparently some white women did not vote
for hillary clinton
in an interview hillary says quote white
women will be under tremendous pressure
from fathers and husbands and boyfriends
and male employers not to vote for the
girl
okay i think i get it so women were
sexist against hillary because they're
too
weak willed against the desires of the
men in their lives
it's definitely not because some women
might have autonomously developed
reasons not to vote for hillary
and although bernie the media and white
ladies share the bulk of the blame
what happened has a lot more pages to
fill and so it offers plenty of other
scapegoats
[Music]
hillary does talk about her own faults
albeit in a way that's um
what's that word wrong what some might
call
constant repeated lying to the press
about financial entanglement she
describes as being
guarded what some might call risking
national security
she describes as being technologically
flawed
she is a bit vague about her flaws so
let's be specific about them we noticed
a few in the book
she compares crowds shouting guilty
guilty at trump rallies to a scene from
game of thrones where crowds shouted
shame shame at cersei lannister did
anyone tell her that cersei lannister is
one of the bad guys
she knows that nurse ratchet isn't the
hero right
was she rooting for scar another example
of her tone deafness is her take on 1984
when describing the purpose of the
torture scene the goal is to make you
question logic and reason
and to sow mistrust toward exactly the
people we need to rely on
our leaders the press experts who seek
to guide public policy based on
evidence that's odd because usually
everyone else interprets 1984
as don't trust the people in power but
there's one person hillary clinton was
right to blame
donald trump in her book hillary called
our 45th man-child in chief
a flagrantly sexist hateful creep and a
clear and present danger to the country
and
the world in response trump retweeted a
gif of himself hitting hillary
with a golf ball but really the main
person at fault for the failure of
hillary clinton is
hillary clinton the best-selling author
of it takes a village to raise children
who will grow up to one day not vote for
you fortunately her new book what
happened is already
top of the list of best sellers on
amazon which is great
because if it wasn't well there'd be
another book
[Music]
you